here we are at the building production
ready ml pipelines with snowflake and
tachyon i'll let its presenters
miles and kevin
take off with their uh with their
presentation
you guys can go ahead
hey everybody uh this session is
building production ready ml pipelines
with snowflake and techton
and uh i will be one of your speakers
today my name is miles adkins i'm a
partner sales engineer
covering our ai and ml ecosystem here at
snowflake
and uh joined today by kevin as well
kevin why don't you say hello to the
crowd yeah hey everybody nice to meet
you i'm kevin co-founder and cto here at
tech town
and uh tecton is an enterprise feature
store for machine learning which was
heavily informed by our learnings from
uber
i was there with my co-founder
a little over three years ago
for several years was working as a tech
lead working on their machine learning
platform called michelangelo
and that's the platform that all the
different data science and data
engineers would use to develop and
productionize machine learning and feed
it into the uber applications to drive
things like fraud detection or eta
predictions or restaurant
recommendations
and a ton of the learnings from that
experience is what at the end of the day
fed into tecton
and that's what we're going to be
chatting about today
yeah and from the snowflake perspective
uh super delighted to have partnered
here with techton we hear from our our
customers all over the place
um all of the challenges that they have
of getting models into production
and even though snowflake is great at
kind of being that end-to-end cloud data
platform there there's still a few
specific areas where
there are some gaps and so
um
you know it's great to have a partner
like tech time to help us here
and so before we dive into
kind of the the the functionality and
the specifics of our joint integration
here i do want to set up a problem
overview
and to
to set the context for this presentation
today a key theme that we are starting
to hear over and over again
especially now that it's 2021 and
you know enterprise ml sas companies
have been a thing for for five or so
years now
is that you know regular companies every
other company out there
that these mlsas providers are going
after are are having a hard time putting
models into production
and most surveys will tell you like
ninety percent of models never see
you know the light of day you have a
data scientist
they go grab some data train a model and
then you know nothing ever happens with
that and
uh the reasons why are kind of all over
the place um
uh you know first of all there's not
enough data scientists in the world um
is is one of the main reasons another
one is
you know business owners don't trust ai
um
it's impossible to monitor our models in
production you name it
now
just like how snowflake was really a
reinvention of the data warehouse for
the modern age which i will dig into a
bit deeper in this session
there really has been no reinvention of
the tools that data practitioners use
today as the industry shifts from being
bi driven to
to ml driven
we are still using a lot of the same
technologies today when it comes to data
orchestration transformation
etc that really weren't meant for use
cases that require predictions and
decisions to happen in real time
okay so what what is missing here to
begin with there's really nothing out
there today that does a good job at
bringing together data that is in a data
warehouse with
live data that is being computed in real
time
whether that's a streaming process
or
you know in real time on a compute
device on the edge somewhere perhaps
now a data scientist can probably join a
few tables together
to you know build a training data set
that will you know better detect fraud
for example
but the the source of that data comes
from a place where you know that data
has already been reconciled after the
fact it's been shoved into a data
warehouse
and uh you know as he trains his model
and wants to go to production
things quickly fall apart when he or she
needs to go and get those live features
to that model in the production
environment
lastly is this idea of feature
consistency across both training and
serving
when defining a feature
you know how do i orchestrate easily
both not just the back filling of that
feature that i need to compute for
generating training data sets but then
how do i also make sure that definition
of
that feature is captured when i go to
serve that feature into production
you know kind of getting those two
things in sync are
are you know it's not an easy lift
and so with using these like legacy data
tools combined with specific
requirements that those tools weren't
designed for
we really uh you know really results in
the following picture that you see here
where a lot of bespoke work has to be
done by
different groups of people over time
and this introduces major roadblocks to
you know really scaling your ai
within your organization
now i'm let you simmer uh
with that for a moment and give a brief
overview of snowflake and then pass it
over to kevin to walk us through how
together techton and snowflake resolve
a lot of these challenges that we just
presented
to give a brief overview of snowflake
snowflake is this end-to-end complete
data platform
it's three layer
architecture enables
unlimitedly scalable storage
of all three types of data structured
semi-structured and unstructured data
it's second layer decoupled computes
allows you to scale on all three
verticals up as your data grows in size
out as more and more users
kind of come online and want to work
with your data
and then across as
different business groups in your
organization look to
uh you know work with the data that
they're that they're driving for
for the business
and then lastly there's the third layer
the services layer which is
what we call kind of the brain of
snowflake that manages governance
security things like
query optimization and data sharing
and most importantly for it to be
delivered as a service based on your
infrastructure cloud of choice
and so you know kind of all combined
you know what this enables is really six
distinct workloads
that span not just
only many of the components of a machine
learning life cycle but many others as
well
and and so even though we have all this
data in one place we have kind of this
single source of truth one copy of the
data in snowflake we have really
unlimited infrastructure resources
on both the storage and compute side
there still lies a gap between ml and
data
and the question is kind of how do we
bridge this gap between the two when
we still need some help generating
things like
point in time correct training sets and
also kind of serving data at high
concurrency and low latency to our
models
and so this is where we have partnered
with tecton
and so with that um
i'm gonna pass it over to kevin now and
he can walk you through the rest of the
the presentation here
awesome thanks miles
yeah so a quick recap tecton is the
layer between your models and your data
it's really the interface between the
two
and what that means in practice is that
techton is responsible for running
transformations against your raw data
that you have stored in snowflake
and it turns those into machine learning
features which your ml model is going to
be trained on or what your ml model is
going to make predictions on
and then it categorizes those features
makes them discoverable
and ends up serving them to your
training system
as well as to your serving system in a
consistent way and that's really key
that's the hard part like how do you do
this consistently so you do not
introduce the feared train serve skew
that's what tekton is built for
and techton does all of that by bringing
the best software engineering practices
over to the machine learning life cycle
by really bringing the devops principles
over where you define features and co as
code
version control them and use the icd to
roll those features out
so let's look at what that user journey
specifically looks like
before we actually show you a real demo
of the integration
the ml feature lifecycle all starts with
a creation of a new feature
and the way you do this with tekton is
completely outside of tekton it's in
python files that you just have on disk
and typically backup by git
and in those python files you
declaratively define your feature
transformation
and for people who have written airflow
dac before this may look quite familiar
where you have a simple python function
with some sql snippet in there that
describes how to use snowflake to turn
raw data that you have in raw data
tables and snowflake
into machine learning ready features
then you decorate this python function
with a feature view decorator that you
see here
and tell tecton how you want it to
manage
that feature
whether you want it to whether you want
those features to be available online or
offline how frequently you want to
refresh those
and all that type of good stuff
and as you ship this feature definition
to techton what it ends up doing behind
the scenes is that it automatically now
does what basically data engineers
otherwise would have to do manually it
compiles the whole simple definition
down to a true physical data pipeline or
multiple thereof
which
turn the raw data stored again in
snowflake into derived machine learning
features that are now ready for training
and serving
and specifically what that looks like
for training
is that tecton
registers a view in snowflake
that you would use to generate your
training data
and here as we see on the next slide you
techton gives you a python sdk that you
can super simply pip install and import
into any python environment that you
have in which you do your training that
could be jupiter lab or it could be
sagemaker data iq any of your favorite
um
favorite model training environments
and use that python sdk to have tecton
basically generate a training data set
for you that consists of as many
different features as you'd like to
select from the feature store
and then besides the python sdk there is
also of course a real-time api that
tekto makes available which is a rest
api or grpc interface
that your
model serving application that's running
in production communicates with to get
the feature vector so imagine you have a
fraud detection model running in
production behind some microservices
running on kubernetes that wants to make
a fraud detection prediction by talking
to an ml flow model running on sagemaker
that microservice needs to fetch a
feature vector that allows the model to
predict whether this transaction is
coming in right now is fraudulent or not
for instance you may not care about the
user's
most recent number of transactions over
the last 24 hours or five minutes or
what have you
and those are exactly the features that
you'd get from tecton so you've got the
microservice calling out detecton
getting a feature vector and then you
end up making a prediction and decide
whether you want to reject or grant
the the transaction
and with that we'll now show you a demo
that our lead pm here matt bleifer who's
been working on this project
prepared for you that shows how tekton
and snowflake were used to drive a ads
serving model
all right
hey let's dig in so as kevin just
mentioned we're going to take a look
today at how we can use techton on
snowflake in order to productionize
features for real-time machine learning
models
in this case we're going to take a look
at an ads prediction problem where we
have ads that we may want to show to a
user and we want to predict whether or
not they're going to click on it
and so let's get started
the first thing i want to do is
check out the existing set of features
that are being used for this ads
prediction model in my organization and
to do that i'll just go to the tecton
web ui here and click on services on the
left and check out this ads prediction
feature service
so feature service and techton just
represents the set of features that we
want to serve for
a particular version of a model and i
can see down below here that we already
have six features that we're computing
representing uh the user's ad impression
counts over various time windows
and the
click counts for a particular ad partner
similarly over three different time
windows
i can see an example coral of how we can
actually hit the rest api from tecton
and get these feature vectors in real
time for a given user and ad partner
and then i can also click on pipeline
here and see
the full end to end lineage of
features that are being computed we can
see we're using an ad impressions data
source from snowflake here
and running two different transformation
pipelines to compute six features in
total those are getting published to our
offline and online store which we then
use for both training and serving
now i can also dig in and get a better
sense of
any one of these features that's
currently being computed so if we take a
look at this
ad impressions counts feature view
a feature view in tecton is just some
transformation pipeline that's computing
one or more features and so i can
similarly dig in and better understand
exactly what transformations are being
ran to compute this feature and how this
data is being materialized
so for example i can see that we have a
simple sql transformation here
followed by
some
built-in techton windowed aggregations
that are efficiently computing these
one-day seven-day and 30-day ad
impression counts
and then ultimately uh yeah we can see
that this data is being published to the
offline and they're already being used
for this model but i want to actually
add my own using some additional data
sources from snowflake and so the first
thing i'm going to do is hop over to
snowflake here
and i can take a look at the various
data sources i have on the left so i
know from experience i already have
these ad impressions and users tables
registered with techton
um but something new i've noticed is
there's this ipinfo database which is
coming directly from the snowflake data
marketplace
and it has this locations table here
which has
data about different locations for
various ranges of ip addresses
now i know that my users table has user
ip information and so i think by joining
these two together i can create some
user location features that i can serve
to my model
so
let's go ahead and register this as a
data source inside of text on and take a
look at what it
takes to define a new feature and add it
to a feature set
so what i'm going to do here is hop over
to what we call a tecton
feature repository so this is just a set
of local python configuration files that
we use to define our data sources our
features and our services again those
sets of features that we want to serve
for a model
so
here i have this datasources.pi file and
i can see the
declarations for the existing ad
impressions and users tables but let's
go ahead and extend this and add in this
iplocations data source that we found in
snowflake
and we can see the configuration is
pretty straightforward here we're just
telling tekton the snowflake account the
database
schema table etc
that it needs to be able to query this
data source
so now that this data source is defined
we can actually build some features
using it and so i'll hop over to this
features.pi file here
and we can see that we have uh the two
different feature view definitions that
we saw on the web ui here computing our
user ad impression accounts and our ad
partner click counts and then we'll add
a third feature view down here
and take a look at how we can compute
these user location features
so
the first thing that tucked on needs in
order to register features is just the
query that we're going to run to
actually compute these feature values so
here you can see a query where i just
joined together the
users and ip locations tables or data
sources that i have registered in tecton
and then ultimately i just select my
user id join key my time stamp that i'm
going to use for these later historical
lookups for training data generation
and then lastly the
remaining columns representing the
feature values that i want to be able to
serve so in this case the city country
and time zone for a given user
so now that we have this transformation
defined the next step is
to tell tecton how to actually
orchestrate and materialize these
feature values so this decorator up top
tells tecton to use these user and
locations
data sources as inputs
we're going to group everything here
around this common user entity which
also defines our user id join key
we're going to tell tecton that we want
this data served online so that we can
fetch it at low latency and do real time
inference but we also want it offline
for training data generation
we want this rematerialized every day to
get new fresh feature values
and then lastly we want this data back
filled to this particular point in time
and so that's it that's all we need to
define our new set of features but the
last thing i'm going to do here is
actually
extend the existing feature set for this
ad prediction model and so we can see uh
here
we have a simple list of features that
we are already serving to this model and
what i'm going to do is
define here a
new version of this feature service
which just adds in these user location
features that we just defined
so now that i've got everything defined
locally what i want to do is actually
register this with the text on cluster
and so to do that
i'm going to run tecton apply
in my cli here and what this does is it
tells tecton to look at my
local
definitions and compare them to what's
registered on the tekton cluster
tekton will notice that we have these
new
data source feature view and feature
service definitions and ask me if i want
to apply these changes i'll say yes
and what we'll be able to see uh
immediately inside of the
web ui here if we just
hop over and do a quick refresh
is we have this user location feature
view now registered
again we can click into the pipeline we
can see
the full lineage and
transformations that are producing these
feature values so this makes it
discoverable by anyone else in my
organization
and then similarly we can see this new
version of our feature service which now
includes these city country and time
zone features
and
likewise the full end to end lineage
of this
particular feature set including this
user location pipeline
something else that i can also see is
that if we go back to snowflake
tecton has actually registered
this feature view directly as a view
inside of snowflake so
we can see here that this user location
view has been registered
and we can actually just get a preview
of the
data that's going to be produced so we
can see again the user id timestamp and
location columns that we care about so
all of this is registered directly
inside of snowflake as well making it
really easy to
check out and explore the different uh
feature views that have been created
with techton
now let's also hop over to our tekton
sdk which is what we're going to use to
generate our training data and we can
see how we can also preview and test out
future views there so we'll go back to
jupiter lab here and we will open up a
jupiter notebook here and just import
the tecton sdk
and just like we ran these views
directly inside of snowflake we can also
iterate in this environment to
test out our feature views using the
tecton sdk which is just a light wrapper
on top of these queries that we're going
to
ship to snowflake
so here we can see we can just grab this
latest feature view that we defined and
run it over a year's worth of data
in order to sanity check things and we
should see something quite similar to
what we saw directly in the snowflake ui
again this data set with our user id
timestamp and location columns
and so now that i'm confident
that this is producing the data that i
expect it to
uh what i'm going to want to do next is
actually generate historical training
data for this new feature set
so to do that the first thing i'm going
to do is load up a
list of training events here which uh
represent users that were shown ads at a
particular point in time and then
whether they did or did not click on it
and what i'm going to want tekton to do
is actually time travel on a
row by row basis here grabbing the
feature values that were valid as of
this point in time
for this set of join keys this is
necessary to prevent any data leakage or
training serving sku and make sure that
our model quality is top-notch
so to generate the training data it's
actually just two lines of code i'll
just fetch that set of features that i
defined for my v2 service pass in this
list of training events
and then ask tacton to get me the data
frame representing those historically
accurate feature values
and so behind the scenes what techton is
doing is constructing this training data
query
to do this point in time join across
these feature views and then ultimately
shipping that query off to snowflake
snowflake is doing all the heavy lifting
for us behind the scenes and we should
get back our data frame of feature
values
great and so there you have it we can
see that we have those original training
events our new user location features
and then also all of the feature values
for those various uh ad impression and
ad partner click counts that we already
had defined in our original feature
service
so this is the data set that we can uh
use to train our model off of but uh
let's also see how we can get this data
online so that we ultimately can do uh
real-time inference and to do that let's
go back to my cli here
and
hit that rest api endpoint for our new
feature service here this v2 service and
we'll ask for a particular user id and
add partner id so this is the case where
we have an ad that we could show to a
user and we want to get back a feature
vector that we can pass to our model
that will ultimately predict if the user
will click on that ad
and what we can see is techton responds
back at low latency with that
latest set of online feature values that
we can use to make our predictions
and so there you have it in just a short
amount of time we were able to
connect a new data source from our
snowflake account uh just define some
features against it register that and
make it available to my whole
organization to discover and reuse then
we were able to extend our existing
feature set for our ad prediction model
with our new with our new feature view
here and ultimately get that data
offline for training and then online for
serving for our model
so i hope you enjoyed this demo and
thanks for watching
just to sum it all up basically what
you've now seen is how techton and
snowflake together really provide you
with a full feature platform that solves
the data problems around machine
learning we've got snowflake at the core
layer the source of truth for all your
raw data and use tecton to manage your
ml features and to serve those ml
features for training and serving
purposes and then finally the only thing
you now really need to
train and deploy ml models is a data
science environment like sagemaker or
jupiter or whatever your data science
environment of choice is to be up and
running and build and deploy real-time
machine learning applications
and then on the next slide you see how
you can connect with us if you want to
try this um integration out if you want
to ask more questions about snowflake or
tekton or the name creation between the
two you can find us in the pi data slack
channel and we also have a separate
tecton feast slack community
that i'd love to welcome you as well too
thank you guys very much for being part
of the
conference this year
and then
everyone should definitely check them
out check them out
you guys have anything you want to add
after that
open for q a if there's any questions
that we have yeah i see a few here in
just the chats uh maybe kevin question
for you
um does does tecton require snowflake or
do you have other options for a back end
yeah we support multiple compute
backends um snowflake spark and native
python are the main compute engines that
we can use to transform raw data into
feature data okay well that's all i see
here again thank you from the snowflake
side
thank you very much
yeah triple thank you guys you have a
wonderful day
you